no io
ciao a tutti ben dorati sui territori
oggi nuova allenza con le pipe ibex si
chiama in italiano
abbiamo giocato una traduzione in serie
nick clegg non di principio della
traduzione sono stati sa che sta scheda
passerella che c'era in cucina si
chiamano anche sac à poche cose sembrano
delle carlo toma metri li abbiamo
riempito un bel po
andremo a pescare dalla scatola così non
possiamo scegliere le tiriamo fuori una
alla volta e poi andremo a fare lo zaino
con quelle che abbiamo pescato come
sempre dovrete votare chi è lo slate
bello per aspetto persone fmr quindi
guardate il video fino alla fine poi di
fare a competere bene lo strike e ti
faremo sentire i suoni lasciate be like
se volete vedere altri challenge fiera
antibiotici premi come proverò a fare il
booking considero andati più fronti in
palazzine più carne ovina tutto schermo
è in te ho subito allora vado a pescare
trans è anche medico ovviamente secondo
voi vi capiterà scrivete nei commenti
pesco la prima a pratiche bel colore o
per scalzo quella sponde
certo barba e colorante viola è
bellissimo
evviva bellissimo che fare con la
trasparenza e quella trasparente
colorante rosa così siamo tutti gli
interventi sociali ei vado a pescare non
pescato il verde mano per furto e lo ha
preso questo allora tutto qua e con la
bianca e colorante colorante turchese
non so come si mischierà il viola
turchese dai no guardate lo guarda
[Musica]
e qui che l'avrei pescatori e vista la
mia figlia ma è capitata lui come si
fonderanno questi due assieme a voi lo
volevo dello store e piazze che scatta
in verde per un bacino che una volta
allora mi sa che qualcuno tanto abbiamo
pescato il cantone roma che si aspetta
offerte e questa è con la bianca con
volante arancione o chiusi o arancione
viola celeste è turchese
dai cappellini uno è un altro dicono va
in testa con la trasparenza e torna
click per il celeste rosa e i cuoricini
rosa impulso se non ti posso capire dove
correrà anche mezzo sarebbe uscito bene
senza trasparente invece per il vento mi
ha detto io quindi se non fai è rimasto
l'ultimo alloro e sembra di sì prendiamo
e ce ne sono ancora dentro la terra non
per caso il rosso è maschi hanno già un
po
pensate cosa trasparente con le altre
una realtà questo è sciocco guardati
fatic intera guardate a tantissimi
twitter ed è uno shampoo che sembra
quella trasparente degli ultimi regali
ne ottiene palline che anni che le
palline piccole palline colorate chi li
vediamo un po ma samuel eto'o cod
abbiamo tra l'altro in grande e se
questo video raggiunto i 10.000 lines
andremo a rifare questa challenge con
questi sacchetti però con la ruota e la
ruota deciderà quali dobbiamo prendere
metteremo i numeri sopra come abbiamo
fatto quella coi guanti allora capire
che questo qui verde e trasparenti una
colla bianca ha portato il colorante
vert nelle palline sono triste ma in
questo colorante verde e mi rovina le
vai indovinare di piccolo riuscirà prima
che lo facciamo
secondo il tipico è quello riuscirà
secondo me il rosso prevalere assemblato
spero quindi perfino aperte ma verde e
rosso io spero che esca rossi in mezzo a
voi provate dominante quando vedi che
con loro c'erano grandi vitale
in base a questi colori scrivete nei
commenti
invece io ho viole celeste turchese e
bianco rosso e scritte e arancione ho
paura che essa un colore scuro e spero
diventi grigio nero
però questo che sia un colore scuro casa
viola scuro esce vuole provare dominare
nei commenti che colora uscirà il mio
sliven vediamo chi indovina e ora
possiamo iniziare a versarli bene
e poi quelli che si chiedevano come
esausto
sto molto meglio grazie mille per essere
stati preoccupati ma dopo giro meglio
quasi del tutto passato era solo grazie
a essere un raffreddore
poi dopo cosa speriamo di fare i video
stiramento tutto il giorno sono
raffreddore ha detto boero aiuto mi
sopporto la mamma mia quanti ragazzi che
non vengono qualcosa e apprendere la
phoebe sembra che stiamo morendo
veramente allora iniziamo a fare dei
nomi reatini sono bellissimi se vuoi
precisi che possa scambiare questo siamo
tutti contenti
tu lo fai tutto bianco e nero faccio
tutto tranne che per dare via verde
dobbiamo iniziare in ordine cronologico
quindi il primo gioco e scatto non avevo
dubbi che il
in quel caso è questo qui in ditte
pronti via e di promesse che strano
perché se del cerchio
credo che ce n'è a cerchio perché la
posta normale sporcato la cornice
oddio non devo stare attenta markiza
tutto per dote questo il mio primo
tratto è già c'è un sacco di roba
mescoliamo l'ho un po e che celeste che
viola forse il colore lo prende dopo
anche passa un po di colorante google
azoto è praticamente già piena
faremo dopo comunque questo è il mio
primo strato penso che uscirà un blocco
in flight ma a questo punto
[Musica]
ma questo non era la sola con la
trasparente e bellissimo un po tutto le
stelline
ma finora il tuo ha un aspetto migliore
del mio allora quale secondo che ho
pescato in un mix tra questo testo non è
ammesso in questo turchese ben ricordato
ok andiamo aprire questo è finalmente
vediamo che cosa farai tu che te con
figliola c'è un sacco di gente che
sembrano fontana andiamo di studiarlo i
colori mischia volo migliore che colori
di menta speriamo non grigio ma che il
secondo strato è fatto tocca a te volete
no io secondo asse con il mio secondo se
lo spazio era il verbo purtroppo
a rovinare tutto con il verde non vedo
l'ora di vedere come ci state da questo
bellissimo sta trasferendo le ha dato
addio caffè robello l'effetto di questo
mix di con la bianca e incolla
trasparente per decisissimo voglio
vederlo mischiato per vedere come
diventa però non il male finora
l'effetto che strano è una sorta di
verde chiaro prova dei brillantini con
delle striature viola sa se il verde sta
proprio andando via forse non si
vedranno e mary a milano e molto neutro
su bianco astra guardando tutto prevedo
un disastro vediamo allora la scavo per
cosa vabbé sono svolge il cantone
veniamo l'arancione come si rischia un
cappello vediamo questi mischia con il
viola
[Musica]
oddio tagliato
lingua in cordate che venne effetto il
mix di colori è sempre bellissimo da
vedere questo stupendo
poi sempre di più a destra sprofonda sta
sprofondando editore la schiuma corregge
il da barba come sale preferite questi
qua con queste sacchette oppure i guanti
quale pensate che sia più bella da
vedere ok andiamo ora a mischiarlo
quindi a molti colori spetta a me sembra
che stia diventando blu ed ecco qua il
risultato finora il terzo è un pescato
io va bene trasparente tutto tra stretta
con glitter e cuoricini rosa
[Musica]
peccato che mischiati con questo verde
speriamo di riuscire
per ora piscina volevi tutto trasparente
invece lo volevi vincere abbiamo finito
però mi sembra che i glitter siano
rimanendo visibili pare gorgonzola ma
che anzi infortunato che si vedono i
glitter almeno un po di colore questo
flight ok ragazzi il mio
l'ultimo sacchetto e poi può andare ad
attivarlo campo stanno sprofondando
vediamo su straborda tutto cambierà
colore odio ma tutti profonda rientro ad
ogni live veramente stabili mobili corso
tra votando non so come farò dati farlo
senza fare un casino ultimato schiena
permessa una storia pallina quindi non
dovrebbe cambiare troppo corre anche
perché ormai anche le altre libertà
vediamo un po come cadono non cadono o
no basta incollare gli appelli a vedere
c'era una collina grosse pure e quindi
un po abbiamo mischiato la pallina e
grandi contro le piccole come faceva
d'attacco chiesto anche dalle bambine
con le piccoline
[Musica]
però vediamo dobbiamo ancora attivarlo
non è mai detto
attivando lo più bello il mio mischia
che i ragazzi abbiamo sfruttato tutti i
pacchetti ore rivolto al momento di
attivarli periodo di non fare un casino
perché stiamo proprio a quindi reni o ad
attivarmi e poi dovrete giocare per
aspetto e per sony s m ok ragazzi ce le
abbiamo fatte le abbiamo attivazione far
vedere una alla volta e come vi dicevo
prima dovrete dare il voto per aspetto e
per sony che inizia sempre io inizi four
che alla fine è diventato una sorta di
violetto chiaro una sorta di lilla
allora le cose positive sono è super
lo sposo è morbido il colore non è male
alla fine anche se un pò chiaro a un bel
colore almeno come uscito lo stop
marrone posti verde quindi la
consistenza il super sulla sponda
vedente ma qua
oddio pubblici per un altro potesse
mettere per lei ti va bene cercando di
vincere
ecco e cercando sul sicuro chi dice
addirittura allora ma la cosa migliore
di questo slime sono i suoni ora ve li
faccio sentire bene
[Applauso]
sentite che un po kling fortissimo
[Musica]
e poi e morbidissimo
[Applauso]
sembra un po vivo persona allora ragazzi
che voto di dosi di aspetto da uno a
dieci edizioni mr da 1 a 10 in più da te
il nome perché non detta anche un nuovo
inizio come chiamato quindi da tempo il
nome nei commenti
[Applauso]
il miur lime qui abbiamo guardare
ebbene questo colore questo colore verde
acqua neve
per questo è un colore verde acqua di
stagno con abbiamo tutte le palline se
giriamo bene troviamo anche le rane che
i cormorani
ora andiamo a presentarlo guardate
guardate che consistenza meraviglioso e
allora innanzitutto è attivato ottiene
non come quello di anitrella tutto nei
campi cicatrice con queste palline il
colore verde si vabbè un po particolare
c'è chi piace c'è chi no
a me no però
linee non vengono stupendo fantastico
adesso facciamo la classica forma del
dello slide questo sembra un panino più
limitata allora e adesso facciamo una
forma classica dello slam
guardate che bella quella ormai classica
arma
mamma mia prova in uscita criminale
rifacciamo la famosa forma classica
dello slide per apprezzarlo in tutta la
sua beltà bellissimo e non è bellissimo
poi a questo punto andiamo a fare i
suoni e cominciamo a controllare
bac kat enti abiti aperture al lo stavo
preparando
[Applauso]
schiaccia il colle che vista che possono
micheletti siano migliorato colpo king
questo è più grande scrivetemi
scrivetelo nei commenti che sono
migliorato per favore poi non è
bellissimo vecchi colori con quanta
elastico
quindi
decidete voi quanto rumore fa quanto è
più bello di liquore decidete voi 4 more
fa in più rispetto a termine e quello
piani perché quanto è bello e poi perché
adesso diciamo la verità come lo fa
leader può king va bene a me lo faccio
io è una cosa mondiale povero sly non
debba far creare bellissimo votate
fatemi sapere nei commenti soprattutto
quanto sono migliorato la rottura c'è
una cosa che non abbiamo mai tanto in
questi video challenge singh qui l'altro
se attivo sull'isola destra no vedeva al
trucco and un'altra persona allora tocca
il mio ricordi ce ufficioso futuro però
fa moltissimo nipponici con un buono
ragazzi avete buttato nei commenti chi
ha vinto vinto io ho vinto vitale
voltate correnti su cui cliccare per
vedere le nostre prossime challenge
altri video divertenti i miei nuovi
video cliccate su quella che preferite e
buona visione
ciao ciao
[Musica]
oddio sono nome sono incinta per finire
la camera non è più distante da
[Musica]
camerieri perde che volevo andare
e quindi diamoci colto è vero ma se
tutto quanto sopra la norma che
riconosce come si guardano si toglie
bene aiuta attenta ed al pc di nuovo
tony questo il claim malefico beh
guardate non so se sia recuperabile
sto cercando di toglierlo la fa ma è
difficile scolarlo ciao